when it comes to iconic hats
nothing says French more than the beret
specifically the Basque style beret as
people wear different styles in other
countries the Basque beret was
traditionally worn by Shepherds tending
their flocks along the Pyrenees mountain
range that divides southern France from
Spain
the vast beret dates back to the 1600s
in southern France made of black merino
wool it has a little cabby you on top
the factory making these braised has
been doing so since 1840 an automated
machine knits undyed wool yarn into a
galette the French word for pancake the
galette is flat and round with loose
knit stitches making it soft and floppy
a worker then pulls the galette central
thread closing it into a circular shape
resembling a shower cap in an
industrial-sized washing machine a
worker washes this rudimentary beret and
lukewarm water from the local river and
soap for about eight hours the type of
soap is a trade secret
the wolf shrinks causing the loose knit
stitches to tighten the wool fibers also
softened transforming into the smooth
and soft woolen fabric we call felt
after felting the beret the
manufacturers begin the dyeing process
the worker loads it into another washing
machine only this time with powder dye
this Factory has always produced its own
dyes in a wide range of colors again
using water from the local river however
the temperature to which this company
heats it is a closely guarded secret
[Music]
when the dye cycle finishes another
worker checks the beret against a color
sample because the wool composition and
the river water quality are variable
factors that can affect dye absorption
[Music]
the next step is to form the beret to
the final shape
traditionally beret factories did this
using wooden forums but today they use
metal ones the beret remains on the form
long enough to lock in the shape this
process too depends on the wool
composition as well as on how humid it
is in the factory on that particular day
each beret goes for a spin on the
scratching machine a rotating wheel
surfaced with wire brushes the bristles
lift the wood fibers thickening the felt
[Music]
after inserting a cardboard template to
maintain the shape a worker uses a
manual shearing tool to carefully
scratch the area around the cab EU she
removes any clinging plant debris left
by the river water used in the wash and
die cycles then she inspects for any
holes or stretched fibres
the beret now goes to the seamstress
first she heats a black cotton lining on
a mold to shape it to fit perfectly
inside the beret the lining has the
manufacturers label in the center which
features the company crest and the model
name true Basque confirming that this is
indeed an authentic Basque style beret
she turns the Brahe inside out to sew in
the lining
[Music]
then she turns the beret right-side out
again and puts it on a stretching
machine she sets the machine to the
desired hat size and it automatically
stretches the beret to that size
[Music]
now she sews a black leather band to the
edge the Hat size is printed on it some
models feature a color trim on the band
the finishing touch is the company's
metal hallmark she rivets it to the
underside of the beret on one side
[Music]
and that caps off production
[Music]
you